Meet the three article brothers: "a", "an" and "the".
All three brothers like to point out nouns.
The twin articles "a" and "an" like to point out singular nouns.
The elder brother "the" likes to point out both singular and plural nouns.
"A" and "an" are usually seen with one person, one place, one animal, and one thing.
Though they are twins, both have different hobbies.
The article "a" is seen with noun that begins with consonants.
For example: a bus, a cow, a girl, a zoo.
The article "an" likes to listen to nouns beginning with vowel sounds.
For example: an umbrella, an octopus, an ink bottle, an elephant.
Come, let's look at a few sentences where these three article brothers appear together.
That is a stall.
There is an umbrella on the stall.
Thus, we can say that articles "a" and "an" are used to introduce a singular noun.
Article "the" is used when we talk about the introduced noun the second time.
In this case, it is "the stall".